all right we have to see how the rest of
the andrew luck situation plays out jim
irsay who i expected would announce
yesterday that
andrew luck will be ready to go for week
one of the 2019 season like he did back
in 2017 a season in which andrew luck
didn't play at all irsay told sirius xm
nfl radio on monday that there is a
little bone issue in the calf muscle
problem that andrew luck is dealing with
it's not an achilles because everybody's
thinking now if you have a calf problem
you're going to tear your achilles
tendon like kevin durant did but still
what's the bone issue is it where the
calf is attaching to the bone is it what
what what is the problem with this calf
that is creating a little bone issue or
is being caused by that how do you fix
it how do you get the guy back this is
just more questions that need to be
answered and the clock is ticking on the
start of the regular season yeah this
this adds another area of intrigue
because we've been told calf muscle calf
muscles soft tissue you think soft
tissue even with a bone issue i mean i
don't think you are or even with like
you know how you're saying where the
muscle attaches to the bone i still
don't think you would say it's a bone
issue i think you you know ultimately
you would say it's still a muscle issue
there so i'm surprised to hear this uh i
really am and and i know we talked about
it on the show earlier but when i hear
this type of thing along with three mris
to figure out a calf injury okay that's
that's odd in itself and here we are
into the third week of of training camp
and we're taking no reps and nobody's
had any answers for us and he's been
resting it for four months
you know again i'm not a doctor and i
don't know these things but that
leads me to believe that maybe there's a
little stress fracture or something like
that that you know doesn't need a cast
doesn't need a boot maybe just needs
more rest whatever it may be i don't
know but i'm very intrigued because this
is a team that i think a lot of people
are putting in the super bowl
conversation uh you know and i
understand that completely and it's a
quarterback who's healthy all year last
year and played like one of the five
best quarterbacks in all of football and
so this is a big deal
yeah and i mean this guy is a giant and
he is an incredible quarterback when
he's healthy he's just had issues the
past few years getting healthy staying
healthy and this is now something new
that has been there since april he's
practiced three times it hasn't healed
and you know chris you from time to time
complain about the quality of the
overall
medical diagnosis treatment that is i
mean how does it take this long to
figure out what's going on and to fix it
i know that they've got millions
invested in the ability of these guys to
play what's going on with these nfl
teams that they're not on the cutting
edge and not instantly like when you
take a car now to the shop they plug
something in they instantly know what's
wrong shouldn't they have technology
like that to find out what's wrong with
an athlete oh well they need to start
paying more to these guys and that's the
biggest issue and yeah they don't stay
up to date on all the cutting edge
technology that's why you see so many
athletes go to specialized doctors and
because of that these specialized you
know doctors or body mechanics and all
of that the nfl is not paying that much
they're not going to go oh i want to go
work for an nfl team and work you know
18 hours a day and deal with trying to
keep 53 man 53 people healthy when they
can go i can just work on 10 people a
day and make 10 times the more money and
that's another issue is the issue with
my own injury when i lost my spleen
that's what really opened my eyes to it
it is still it's kind of prehistoric as
far as what the nfl tries to do and
their rehab and their thought and their
process there it's not up to date with
some of the more cutting-edge guys that
are out there and you know involved in
other sports and training guys you know
personally and doing all that it's
definitely an issue for the nfl
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports